U.S President Joe Biden on a tour to
strengthen ties in the Asia Pacific
in Phnom Penh he met Cambodian prime
minister Hansen host of this year's
asean and other Regional leaders at the
summit the message he carried was clear
that the United States is committed to
its strong ties in the region
today we take another critical step
beginning a new era in our cooperation
with the launch of the U.S asean
comprehensive strategic partnership
together we will tackle the biggest
issues of our time from climate to
health security
defend against the significant threats
of rule-based order to rule-based order
and and to threats to the rule of law
elsewhere in the capital Chinese Premier
League was meeting cambodia's King the
strained relationship between China and
the U.S in recent years has left many
Southeast Asian Nations torn between
choosing Chinese investment or U.S
security guarantees the meeting next
week between Xi Jinping and Joe Biden
will be watched closely here
and closer to home the issue of Myanmar
raised once again after a week's
statement on Friday from asean an
acceptance from the un's Secretary
General
that it was not just Regional leaders
who were letting down the people of
Myanmar everybody has failed in relation
to Myanmar The International Community
as a whole has failed and he went is
part of the International Community
it is dramatic to see the suffering of
the myanmaris people
and this is the start of a week that
will see major meetings in Bali and
Bangkok too and leaders from across Asia
and Beyond were getting the business of
international diplomacy underway
with just the closing ceremony ahead
this has been perhaps a less contentious
asean Summit than many people expected
and many Southeast Asian leaders will be
reassured by the message they heard from
U.S President Joe Biden today the United
States is committed to this region a
message that will be reassuring with
troubled economic Waters ahead Tony
Chang Al Jazeera Phnom Penh